in tonight's speech the president is
expected to highlight the growth of the
american economy after the pandemic and
by many measures the numbers are indeed
on his side unemployment is down wages
are up and the economy overall is
expanding rapidly however costs for the
typical american family are also up and
more americans say they are struggling
to pay their bills today than six months
ago in our recent poll more than half of
the people this is out this morning say
they are concerned about their ability
to pay for everyday essentials like gas
and groceries we spoke with one middle
class family that says in the middle of
this so-called recovery they feel left
behind
when we first met gabenell and his
family outside their home in beacon new
york he like much of the country was in
a state of economic shock this has never
happened before this has never happened
before it was march of 2020 and gabe had
just lost his job as a sound engineer
for a company doing corporate events
we were there the day of his last
paycheck so april 1st are you going to
make a mortgage payment or not
good question we haven't even talked
about that we've since returned three
more times most recently last week where
we heard something that may surprise you
you think the last time you guys would
be here it'd be great
but this is probably the worst
that i've ever been
even as president biden touts his
economic record after my first year as
president the united states had the
fastest economic growth in nearly four
decades people like gabe are still far
from recovery how do you think the blind
administration is doing
i don't see it working for us
i don't we don't see it
you want to after the last
administration you want to be like yay
they're helping us and they made all
these promises and then you just see
everything going down the tubes
good two full years now into the
pandemic gabe's career hasn't bounced
back
and even with his wife claudia earning
income as a property manager the annells
recently had to make the difficult
decision to ask relatives for help it's
embarrassing i don't like it
oh my goodness and claudia fears the
rest of the country has already moved on
it's just a long time
and people are tired and i don't think
people or the government or anybody
is really all that worried about
how people are getting by anymore
you rack your brain for an explanation
for why two years in you're at a
financial low point what do you come up
with
definitely no assistance
for a time when this country definitely
needs help more than 72 million
americans say they are struggling to pay
their expenses a number that's actually
grown by about 2 million people a month
since last august
and it's not hard to understand why with
inflation at a fresh 40-year high
the average american family is paying an
extra 250 dollars every month just to
live like they used to
pretty much everything's going up but
not our
not our pay
so you know it's it's it's very
difficult to not be mad the family had
been getting by thanks to the government
stimulus checks and extended
unemployment benefits and when we spoke
to them a year into the pandemic claudia
in particular felt seen and supported i
don't feel as
skeptical as i did last year because
last year i just really felt like wow
we're just going to be in an island you
know
but this year i feel like okay
i think the government is hearing us and
trying
to get somewhere but now those benefits
are gone and like so many other middle
class families the anells have had to
cut back don't go out anymore
drive as the least amount as possible
because gas prices are insane
oil prices for the house not doubled but
pretty close wow so you know now we're
very very very frugal
what about food
like we told our son no more snacks
and all of the essentials now you know
odd jobs like seasonal delivery driver
and garage attendant have helped but
only some
17 15 hour full-time job is not going to
pay any bills it's not going to pay
anything you know it's only going to
help if you have another job on top of
that and even with occasional freelance
audio work that pays much much better
the family is falling behind definitely
all credit card payments are not
happening credit card payments are just
not happening they're just not going to
happen right now not even the minimum no
i can't even make the minimum
because i'm prioritizing for car
payments
mortgage payments oil payments
gasoline to get to these jobs gabe is
still hopeful his old job will bounce
back eventually but until it does the
inels like so many other families are in
a state of economic
and emotional distress
it makes me angry it makes me feel
defeated
and it's hard to watch my husband go
through it because he is a very
very intelligent person he's a very
capable person
he's a hard worker um
and
it's just unfair to have everything just
sort of taken away when we first spoke
to you
you thought maybe this would be over in
three months maybe six nine months with
something that was being floated
did you ever in a million years think
we'd be here two years later
no as a matter of fact we were very
hesitant about doing this because we
were like do people really want to keep
hearing about how terrible everyone's
doing
you know it felt like kicking a horse
while it's down kind of thing
and we decided yeah because it's
important because maybe people don't
realize that it's still happening maybe
people are in their own bubble
and feeling like everything's hunky-dory
now and it's not
so it's it's definitely not as a matter
of statistical fact hunky-dory right now
census numbers were like one in three
families struggling to pay their bills
our poll out this morning says most
americans are concerned about paying
their bills and it's all about where you
started and you're trying to hold on to
where you were so he's saying 1750 is
not paying his bills for someone else
that's good enough right he's sliding
down the economic ladder and he's afraid
and a lot of americans have that fear
right now here's where i was two years
ago and i'm dying to hold on and i feel
myself sliding back it's scary it's
relative to your financial circumstance
but i'm slipping and it feels like i'm
drowning right now in the deep end
exactly and understand their frustration
and pain especially if you hear the
biden administration say things are
better you know that the economy is on
the upswing things are better so i
admire the fact that he said we were
reluctant to do it and then we thought
no we really need to tell people there
are still a lot of people in trouble a
lot and a lot of people still even if
your wages went up if inflation is
higher than your wages you actually got
a pay cut yeah what's his original job
audio he was an audio engineer for big
corporate events and they haven't
bounced back well i will say the company
that he used to work for hired one of
the two workers back so he may get some
good news in the days ahead we'll see
we're hoping yeah or another company or
another company a lot of people can
identify with that family these are
stories that we need to hear yeah